always on top of the important news the
New York Post has a report this week
about 28 year old cyber security analyst
Lucy who according to the headline
identifies as a proud adult baby who
wears diapers
though Lucy cautions that her proclivity
is certainly not a sex fetish it's not
that at our at all she says sure it is
Lucy whatever you say now this article
on the one hand falls squarely into the
Sideshow circus category in accordance
with a long tradition stretching back
centuries of traveling freak shows where
onlookers are invited to come and gawk
at all the weirdos these shows have
taken on different forms over the years
and these days they take the form of
Journalism but on the other hand there
are actually some important lessons to
be gleaned from Lucy's story if you can
believe it we are living inside of a
Perpetual freak Show that's our our
cultural identity really and so we can
we can learn something about our own
situation from cases like this I think
you know guys this job gets really hard
sitting here and talking into a camera
it's it could be even traumatic
sometimes a very difficult job to do
especially with all the purple-haired
weirdos that I have to
watch and react to every single day
that's why because it's no easy task I
always have to find ways to cope and to
Center myself again that's why I use the
Hallow app hello is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the US it's like
calmer headspace but rooted in Catholic
faith as opposed to the religion of
leftism hello offers over 5 000 audio
guided prayers meditations and Christian
music tracks as well some of the most
popular prayers include the daily Rosary
Gospel reading and the daily Psalm with
Bishop Baron they also have prayers led
by Mark Wahlberg Mario Lopez Jim cadizel
and Jonathan Rooney hallow helps me find
peace and calm throughout the day even
as crazy leftists yell at me through a
tiny screen still I stay peaceful let
Halo help you find your peace too so go
to hollow.com Matt Walsh and get an
extended three month free trial during
which you'll have access to all 5 000
plus meditations and prayers that's
hello.com Matt Walsh for three months
free reclaim your piece in this crazy
world download hello today so the New
York Post tells us quote
a 28 year old cyber security analyst has
revealed she loves wearing diapers and
dressing up as an infant and says
there's no shame in her unusual interest
Lucy has not disclosed her surname but
is a proud member of the adult baby
diaper lover community and frequently
posts photos of herself wearing the
Disposable underwear quote I didn't find
out about adult babies and that they
existed until I was a teenager and I did
some Google searching of my own
she told media drum World until then it
never occurred to me that there would be
more people like me it's not about Kink
it's about Comfort she defiantly tells
haters who label her a sick fetishist
Lucy holds down a regular white collar
job and has a normal love life but cruel
trolls have told her that her former
boyfriends must be pedophiles if they're
dating a woman who wears diapers and
sucks on pacifiers
well there may not be pedophiles legally
might not be emphasis on might but um
one might argue that there are that they
are pedophiles and Spirits at the very
least we learn more quote Lucy says her
interest in wearing diapers began after
her baby sister was born I was eight or
nine years old when I first got these
feelings and it was very confusing she
explained the blonde started stealing
her sister's diapers and wearing them
for Comfort although she rarely relieved
herself in them we are assured Lucy has
found support from others in the ADL
community and shares snaps of herself
dressed as a baby on Instagram
now
if you're you're paying close attention
and I wouldn't blame you if you weren't
this may all sound eerily familiar and I
don't just mean familiar in the sense
that there are many adult babies in
America today even if most of them don't
identify as such I mean familiar in that
Lucy sounds exactly like other
communities of people who identify as
something other than what they are
just like the gender identity Brigade
she says that she discovered this truth
about herself when she was a child
she says that living this way makes her
feel more at home and at peace with
herself she denies that it's a sexual
fetish just as
um men who wear women's clothes deny
that it's a fetish even though in both
cases it has the appearance in all the
Hallmarks of a sexual fetish she even
discovered her own Community with its
own acronyms letters that have not been
accepted under the LGBT umbrella yet but
will be soon enough we can be sure in
fact the trans age community
has a greater claim to validity and
acceptance than the transgender
Community age after all does actually
change over time it is fluid in that way
and unlike a man who says he's a woman
an adult who says that they feel like a
child can speak with some measure of
authority on the matter because they
were once a child and therefore know
what it's like to be a child because
they were one once now this doesn't mean
that trans ageism is actually valid of
course it's still totally deranged and
the only community that such people
should share should be found inside of a
mental hospital but the point is simply
that we as a culture have already
accepted and tolerated and legitimized
self-identifications even more baseless
outlandish and incoherent than this the
adult baby is downright tame and
traditional compared to the Life Choices
we already celebrate and throw parades
for
that's why these various other
communities of fetishes in denial
are are not really the sideshow circus
that we want them to be
the um trans age people the trans
species people
furries the so-called Neo pronoun users
people who identify as clouds and trees
and space aliens and so on along with
the polyamorous thruples and the
objectum sexuals who wish to be bonded
in wedded bliss with buildings and
bridges and all that
and the whole bizarre assortment of
countless other categories of weirdos
and mutants these are not
Fringe aberrations but rather they are a
gathering flood pressing against a dam
that cannot hold
as a society we no longer have the
language or the basis for denying the
validity of any alternative lifestyle no
matter how perverse it is
all of these communities to include most
especially uh the pedophiles who've
already helpfully been rebranded as
minor attracted persons Maps quote
unquote
all of them can stake their claim to
acceptance using all of the same
arguments and all the same buzzwords and
catchphrases that have already won the
day
culturally speaking
this is the point of the slippery slope
argument which is fallaciously written
off as a fallacy by people who would
prefer for us to be surprised by what
comes next they don't want us to predict
it but in fact the slippery slope is not
really a prediction uh or a guess or a
theory even less it is a is it a
prophecy
it's actually just an observation
about things that are happening right
now we observe
that the justifications offered on
behalf of one thing
could just as easily be applied to these
dozens of other things that already
exist
and so
if we accept the first thing then we've
already accepted all of those other
things
whether we meant to or not
that's the slippery slope
one other point about this as always
you know it'd be impossible to overstate
the effect of the internet and social
media here because a question that often
comes up
and then I get asked a lot is is is uh
you know whether I think that all of
these perversions
which have been normalized in our
culture did they exist in the past
um but most people simply never heard
about them or or have we invented them
in modern times I think the answer to
that is yes and no
the human mind
since the fall of Man has been a dark
and twisted place that was as much the
case 100 years ago and a thousand years
ago as it is today the difference
is that prior to the internet
and modern media a person with one of
these sorts of proclivities
would have nowhere safe to go to explore
it anonymously and without fear of
public shame
they would then have no choice but to
suppress it to try to overcome it to try
to live a life in spite of it
ignore it whatever it is and often they
were successful not always but often
but today
a person can Plumb the depths of their
own psyche
identify all the weirdest and most
objectionable aspects of themselves and
after a quick Google search as we heard
from Lucy there find communities of
other people who share this exact same
kind of psychological disturbance
and then they can then feed and Foster
what people in the past would have
suppressed and they could do it with the
cloak of anonymity until they're ready
to announce themselves to the world
and then when that time comes
they know that they'll be accepted and
celebrated
just so long as they show Pride
they have to show pride in it
because the only thing they can do wrong
where this proclivity is concerned
or where any lifestyle quote-unquote
lifestyle choice is concerned is to
publicly betray any shame or
embarrassment about it that's the one
thing you can't do
because these days in our culture shame
is really the only sin
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the Subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast